we begin with breaking news U.S
authorities say all flights in the
United States have been grounded because
of a system failure the Federal Aviation
Administration says more than 400
flights have been delayed within into or
out of the United States because of a
technical glitch it's unclear what's
behind this the Federal Aviation
Administration has tweeted in the last
few minutes it says the FEA is working
to restore its notice-to-air emissions
system we are performing final
validation checks and we're reloading
the system now operations across the
national airspace system are affected
we're going to provide frequent updates
as we make progress well Kimberly
halcard our White House correspondent is
joining us on the phone now Kimberly
this is a very large scale incident what
more do we know
yeah this is something that the Biden
Administration is grappling to deal with
right now this is something that is
unfolding in real time what we know is
that this is something that involves the
flight notification system that is for
the entire United States and you can
imagine the scale of this is enormous
the the passenger travel in the United
States affects tens of thousands of
people on a daily basis there is no idea
whatsoever of when this could be
restored this involves something called
the not have or the notice to air
missions and what it does is it
essentially helps to advise a sort of an
emergency uh sort of flight awareness
for the those that are operating the
overall air traffic and to the pilots
and so obviously firstly if this is not
functioning the whole system is not
functioning so what we know is that
there are according to the Federal
Aviation Administration uh that this is
something that is being attended to this
is obviously critical infrastructure in
the United States this is being treated
with the but most of most of importance
we are not being given any information
about how this has suddenly become an
outage we only know that this is in
Peril at the moment but we have no
understanding of why we also have no
understanding of when it will be
restored so you can imagine the chaos
because this is a regular Work Day in
the United States people right now are
already at the airport this is a regular
business travel day I myself am in the
Northeast quarter which is a heavy
business travel area between Washington
DC and Boston New York City Los Angeles
Chicago Atlanta all of these major hubs
they are regular hubs for business
travel all of the people at 7 A.M
Eastern Standard Time where I am right
now are getting on planes to go to
business meetings to even in the time of
of zoom and and teleconferencing people
still do physical travel and so this is
going to be a time when airports are
packed and this news is going to inject
chaos into the travel system in the
United States now once again the FAA and
they're alert and it's very very short
says there is no estimate for when there
will be restoration of service there is
only a hotline which has been put in
place in order to try and give people
further notification but right now
there's very little information coming
out for passengers Kimberly thank you
very much indeed we're going to be
checking in with you as this story
develops but for now thank you